I don't really have any anything to say
other than what the family said
yesterday
um my whole focus is are two girls
just staying as strong as I can for them
scared that if I
put any focus into anything else
it's gonna take my you know Focus off
that so I've got to be very careful
just hope into goodness
that anything comes out from the
interview yesterday not my our tiny
uh just say a massive thank you to the
community friends
for everything that
that they're doing it's absolutely
incredible
I just can't believe that that we can't
and as yet
it seems like we're no further on it's
just just seems it just seemed
absolutely impossible
just
like a dream it's cannot get made around
any of it
I mean your left sort of trying to make
sense of the of the sense of something
it is just such a mystery
yeah it
it is there's just now EV every single
scenario
comes to a brick wall every single one
of them and then all we're doing is
sitting there going around around going
through every scenario and then go back
to the first scenario again and do the
whole thing again and then
I think it's just all day long that's
all we're doing that's all we're doing
how are how are you coping it must be so
difficult like say your focus is is on
the girls and it has to be but yeah it
must be so difficult I don't know how
I'm coping I I don't even want to
actually think about that just focus
just like I say it's just about the
girls that's it I'm there for them
um
I don't want to really elaborate on that
I just
although I take my eye off that it must
be heartwarming to see the public
response hundreds of people trying to
help it's amazing it's uh it is right
now it's the only thing that we can take
is you know that level of support
is out of this world
um it gives us a great amount of comfort
knowing that they're that's going on
they don't have anything else do we well
there's hope there's yeah we're never
ever going to lose the hope of course
we're not
uh but like but right now
it is as though
she has vanished into thinner like
yeah just hit him just insane